Hello, and welcome back to Rawkode Academy. This
is a new episode of Custard.
I have been away for three
months, almost three months now. And so I
don't remember how to do any of this
live stream and stuff. I don't even know
if my little video is gonna pop up
at the bottom and stuff.
It's just been far too long. But today's
episode of Clustered, we have two great teams,
two very broken clusters, and we're gonna do
our best to work through all of those
fixes and get things jamming today.
Now, before I bring on our first team,
I wanna thank our sponsors for today's episode
of Clustered. Teleport have been sponsoring Clustered from
the very beginning. We've been using Teleport from
the very beginning and they recently started sponsoring
us. So Mads Props Teleport has been great
working with you. If you like what you
see as we use Teleport to debug and
fix these clusters today, you should just check
out rockode.liveteleport
to show your support. It really helps and
I will thank you much later. Also the
hardware has been provided by my former employer,
Equinix Metal. If you want to try it
bare metal cloud, you go
to metal.equinix.com.
And when you have an account, use the
code Rawkode, this will get you $200 of
credits to start kicking the tires. These are
some pretty nice and beefy machines. So
have some fun with them, I do.
All right, now we're going to meet our
first team for today.
Here
we go. You are all now live on
air. So mind what you see,
be polite, all that jazz. Can we start
at the top right? We'll start with you,
Christian. Just say hello, tell us who you
are, and then we'll move round clockwise.
Alright. Hello. My name is Christian Laxina, and
I'm with RXM LLC. We are a cloud
native training
and
and engineering company.
That's me.
Hi. I'm Christopher Hansen. I'm, one of the
instructors for RXM. I also I'm a cloud
happy to be here. Thanks for having us.
Good good evening and good morning. My name
is Ron Petty. I am also
an employee of RXM. I'm a consultant.
We we work on books and trainings and
we love Kubernetes and we're we're glad to
be here. Thanks for the opportunity.
I think I made a mistake.
I just went to my YouTube page and
I'm streaming to the wrong video. So how
wonderful is that for a start. Right?
Mother shit.
The first thing's been hacked. Yeah.
But the comments are coming from the the
right video.
Is this a bug with my streaming software?
Good question. Because I'm seeing the comments
from my video, but I'm very clearly streaming
to part seven of a teleport course. Alright.
I'm gonna hit finish. Just change over and
see what happens.
Alrighty.
Should burn my streaming software.
Alright.
So we get to do our things all
over again? Well, I've just pushed the live
button again. I'm gonna keep us here, and
then we're gonna see what the hell is
happening. I don't know what.
Here we got some comment rolling in now.
Russell. Hello.
Russell. Yeah. I'm gonna wait till I confirm
that it's working and then I'll There we
go. But it's off to a fantastic start,
I've gotta say. I'm really, really happy with
that.
Yeah.
Thanks for that.
It's still not coming through.
Do it live.
Alright. I'm just gonna post a comment
with
the other video because my streaming software is
YouTube
being weird.
Now we got a couple of top chats
already.
Yeah. So, I mean, the people are just
tuning in there. I have no idea what's
going on. The chat from
the real video is coming to my software,
but the stream is going
to a different video.
So I'm going to assume this is a
YouTube bug. I have no idea.
But we're just gonna roll with it now
and get started. I posted the video link
and it's come through on the same chat,
which is even weird.
But we're just gonna get started. There's 21
people waiting in the other video and I
hope they'll find their way over here.
Alright.
So
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna be really
horrible. I'm sorry. Could you all introduce yourselves
again and then we'll get started on today's
cluster?
No worries.
I guess I'll go ahead and get started.
My name is Christian Laxina. I'm with RXM,
and we are a cloud native training and
consulting company.
Happy to be here.
Yeah. Thanks for having us. My name is
Christopher Hansen. I'm also a team member at,
RXM. I'm a cloud native engineer and instructor.
Super excited.
Right on. And and the the third wheel.
My my name is Ron Petty. I'm a
consultant at RXM,
and I am also very excited to be
here.
Alright. Thank you all.
Alright. Well, I think we just dive straight
into this cluster. Let's see if we can
get this thing working. So this first cluster
is from our second team who are at
Raft Tech.
I'm going to pop my screen up here
and we have our teleport session.
I'm going to click connect
and open a
root terminal
on our control plane node. Now, if you
can all go to activity
and active sessions and join this, and once
you're in, if you just type echo, hello,
whatever, let me know that you're there. Can
see we've got one more person connected,
two more,
you know, yep, four, there we go. Perfect.
So we're all in the same session.
This would be a good time for you
to configure your KubeConfig and test to see
if we have an API server.
I'll let you all take it from here,
but have
fun and best of luck.
Alrighty. Thanks. Thank you, David.
So Alright. Let's go ahead and, get ourselves
going.
I believe there should be an export statement.
Nope. Let's, we don't have an export statement.
So let's go ahead and
do config view.
So, basically, what's happening here right now is
it looks like my kubectl is being pointed
to the correct well,
yeah, it's being pointed to the correct file,
but I don't seem to actually have, well,
the ability to access it.
So
let's see here.
Okay.
Oh.
Looks like the config is belonging to root.
I just happen to be root as well.
It's read write.
It's not in the path. It's a little
weird. Which
keeps CTL.
Alright.
And it's not an alias
unless I'm missing it.
Nope.
Doesn't appear to be.
Well, what does that
that mean?
Alright.
So it's not an alias.
It's so it would normally be, like, user
bin kubectl.
Let's be pedantic here.
It is there, but no permission. No permissions.
Interesting.
User
and KubeCTL.
Which KubeCTL?
We're almost back to life.
Maybe. We'll see.
Alright. Alright.
Now now, Christian,
export. Go.
Alright. So
we'll do we'll then do the export or
cube config. So, usually, I believe these are
cube ADM clusters. Right? So let's see. If
I do l s minus l or well,
I am rude, actually. Etsy
let's see. Kubernetes. Okay. Etsy cube ADM. Is
that correct?
Ron and Chris, go ahead and yeah. Oh,
here. Let me
yeah. It should be a Etsy Kubernetes
admin. So there's that. So then if you
do export equals That's right. Let's see.
ADM.
Enter.
And then kubectl
get pods.
Oh, it's export cube config. There we go.
Oh, yep.
One one one would break.
Yeah. Yeah.
So for the audience, what we're doing is,
we're actually pointing our KubeConfig
our KubeCuddle to use the admin KubeConfig.
This is actually something you can only do
as root.
So let's see here. It doesn't look like
the admin conf is working at this point.
Interesting.
So
let's see here.
No.
Ron, let's see if we act
Let let's see if we actually got the
correct
oh, what is that?
Oh, okay.
So let's see if we actually have the
correct environment variable name. What do you think,
Ron or Chris?
Yeah. But I'm
pretty sure that was right.
Yeah. It seems that way.
I mean, we could be a little more
Yeah. Yeah. That's true.
Or
Etsy Kubernetes.
I'm like, I can
I
can spell? Okay.
And I mean, one well, I mean, it's
clearly reading it. I I guess I guess
I was being dumb there. It is reading
it because it wouldn't have the IP address
otherwise. Right? So That's
Yeah. I'm I'm I'm afraid
to oh, no. I I turned off my
plug in, so this teleport here should should
work here. So let's take a
over a few. Is
that the IP of this machine? Yeah. That's
what I was gonna check too.
144492866443.
So let's just try Telnet. 136.
So the IP address is a BGP advertised
address to this machine.
I think it's safe to say that it
is correct.
Yep. So HTTP or yep. And then
TLS.
So
that would imply
oh, let's see. Crap.
Sorry. So PS,
Waxa,
Grep,
Cube API.
I always love to see which parameters people
use with PS. Well, nobody seems to use
the same one twice.
So look at the advertised address there.
Yeah. That ain't, that's not correct. That's, well,
it's, it looks like that's the local address.
Yeah. So let's just take a look there.
So, 10 Dot 25212133.
So that should be okay.
Okay. Then
it
where's the HTTPS
privileged
stuff? Alright. So many settings.
Well, privileged
author.
I really have a hard time reading these
multilayer things.
Find
Where's the setting to enable TLS
or disable? I can't
Let's see. Oh, yeah. The secure report is
actually there. So minus my secure report is
in there. Ideally,
insecure report should be absent here for you
security minded folks.
And I don't think I see that. I
wanna move that if you guys are reading.
But
yeah.
Yeah. Go for it.
Chris, what was So
oh, I just was looking. I just wanna
look at the YAML file. It's a little
bit easier to read the flags.
It's best to put it through a pager
just so that we can follow the Yeah.
Line of sight as well rather than we
have to scroll to where I think you
are. So
Fair enough. I'm looking at the flags right
now. Yeah. Perfect.
Alrighty.
So our advertised address is different
from what's in the KubeConfig,
so it seems.
At least it should be.
Oh, yes.
Yeah. So maybe just switch this, you're saying?
Yeah. Give it a shot. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So
what was it? 10 dot
I copied it. You can scroll up. Yeah.
Not cool. This is I meant
This is the 1361444928
numbers over here.
Gotta be interesting.
No.
Stop.
Alright. Add it here. Read.
Write.
What?
Uh-oh. What's going on here? I'm gonna sledgehammer
this because I'm I'm simple.
Oh,
come on. Is this the Oh. Is it
is AppArmor
No. Did they disable
did they disable our VI
as well? No. The professions of VI. Oh,
come on. They they did.
Those dirty
dirty
who
would hurt VI? Just use Emacs. What?
Well, they'll never get out of it.
Alright. User bin. I'm gonna guess it's
alternative.
Alright.
Etsy alternatives.
Let me guess. It's it's gonna go to,
like
user. Oh my god.
User.
And not basic. Oh my god. All these
aliases.
There we go. CH mod
seven zero zero user.
Thirty. I don't I thought I like GoRaft
as a team, but I don't know. You
mess with them. You you mess with my
family.
Alright. Did that work? Hey. We're alive. Alright.
Kubernetes.
Copied something into my buffer, so I'm thinking
I'm gonna bork this.
Oh, no.
I locked out. My plug in hold on.
Let me it's this plug in. Let me
add add a rules, save changes.
Ernie, my plug ins my plug in is
a VI plug in for Chrome.
What was the IP again?
Oh, man.
There oh, I do have it. Alright. Hey.
6443.
Oh, wait. We we
we can't use comments.
No. That's lovely.
Alright. So I get.
Let's see.
Alright. And 2562.
Make sure nothing else has changed in the
meantime. 6443.
Is refused.
Interesting.
Stat.
Nothing
is listed on 6443.
Yeah. Alright. So what happened there? So I
think we need the
more observational
view here.
So Airport 6443.
Where'd you say you saw the insecure?
Oh, I I don't think it I don't
think it was there. Truly. Yeah. It's not
there.
Let's see. I think I think it was
he was just using
just talking
for education purposes. You know? It shouldn't be
on.
That's the teacher in in Christian.
Yeah. Alright.
So
we are secure port 6443.
So it should be,
doing
now,
usually,
doesn't the, Kube API server run on the
host network?
So can we check if this has,
host network true?
Yes.
One
second.
Go.
And host network is true. Alright. So it's
definitely
it should be listening on that address and
that port. Yeah. Let's take a look at
the logs.
Oh, wait a minute. We can't connect it,
so we have to do tail
dash
whatever.
Oh, it's just tail at the start. Var
log
Kubernetes.
Yeah.
Done.
Failed to con
two, three oh, etcd. A local host. Yeah.
Everybody's favorite component.
So
I'll make sure it's yeah.
No. It's not. No etcd.
What's going on here?
Let's check it for the Do have the
manifest is in there? Yep. Yep. Yep.
It's there. Let's see if the but let's
see if it's actually valid.
Or read only or n empty.
K. So v or let's
cat
Etsy Kubernetes.
Alright.
And it's advertising
it's not advertising on the local host. It
appears to be advertising on the
on the node's IP.
See that first flag up there, Ron, on
advertised client? Oh, that's client URLs. Excuse me.
Yeah. So hold on. We should if it's
not starting, there should be a log somewhere.
Right?
So Etsy use log should be a pod,
but we can't get to the API server,
or can we? So so this is a
static pod. So where do static pod logs
go?
They
do they always go to
do we just not think about
this? Is it
alright.
There's at CDs.
See, no such directory.
Oh, let me guess. We've port our certs.
Okay. So let's take a look at this
guy.
What's
in there?
Okay.
So it'd be peer, that cert. Or
well
So
well, let's see if it's just hidden or
something.
Or
wait a minute. Client is
sorry. Let me use my brain here. So
this is FCD that's failing to start because
it can't find it for client
client.
I guess we could just use a peer
cert. What is
as long as they all have the same
CA, it shouldn't matter. Right? Right.
Well, yeah, we don't really care about the
clients.
Yeah. Right. We don't care about the clients,
but let's check that out, the API server
real quick. The client cert, though. So
Yeah.
It's a redial probably because it can't talk
to that CD.
So this guy
let's see. What is he using?
API server at CD client.
Client cert.
My god. I'm having a brain fart here.
Yeah.
No. No worries.
So it looks like here, those are all
pretty standard for the API server.
But it seems like ETCD itself, can we
check the spec for it?
Seems like ETCD itself is trying to refer
to that client dot CRT, which clearly doesn't
exist. So let's see if we have a
client dot CRT somewhere.
Go ahead and type it in. Well, it's
not yeah. That's what we're looking at, the
Etsy Kubernetes.
That's this
directory. It's not
I guess, pure cert is what we're supposed
to use, maybe.
Cert file is client dot CRT.
So I think
Oh, point it to Kubernetes.
Yes. I don't remember what was in the
directory.
Oh, what was in the directory was I
don't know if you can see highlights here,
folks. But Oh, wait. I I got it.
I found it. It's at c d Kubernetes
PKI API server.
Or, mean, it should it should be the
thing we
were ignoring before.
Yeah. But this
but it looks like this error here is
referring to that. So I believe this should
be the server dot c r t.
Oh, yeah. Cert file. Duh. Yeah.
So that's the server cert.
Cert. And if this is a one this
is a one node cube ADM master. Correct?
It is.
Alright. So that means that
it will eventually come up.
Or it crashed so fast.
Yeah. So
let's go see.
Oops.
Here. Anything NCD?
No. That's I think that's it. Yeah.
Yeah. But I I can never remember if
it
changes. So we just wanna see that
time stamp is updating. Right?
But did
should it did change.
It doesn't align. I can't read it.
Alright. It was twenty three, so let's just
watch it.
Oh, it did up twenty four now. So
it should be Yep. Should be there. Yeah.
Your tool command is using the API server
instead of the STD log.
That's not the STD log?
There it is. So what's this now? Ah,
c a a cert. Too many too many
a's.
You trying to are you trying to speak
the SLA of our certificate?
Shall I make sure a, man.
Yes. Go for it. Yeah. Okay. The cone
the cone of shame is yours.
Alright. So c a a dot c r
t. Alright. This is a oh, that's sneaky.
Alright. Let's go before we leave, let's go
to the if it was them.
Let's
see. So
I'll take back the Koenig then.
Yeah.
Peer cert. Peer cert.
Alright.
So
let's go ahead and try it. I do
recall that the API server is also trying
to connect on local host, but we'll see
how that oh, wait. No. It's still One
one one problem at a time. Time. Yeah.
Yeah. One.
Alright. So at time.
Or watch this again. Lookup magic.
Before. So It's twenty five after, so it
should oh, there it goes. It's been deleted.
I feel like this watch default setting of
two seconds is more than two seconds.
Right?
It should, like,
be, like, a little spinner or something to
prove that it
did something. I guess on the right, it
is. I think that's the clock. Yeah. Yeah.
There it is. Alright. I guess I'm impatient.
I should read the whole thing.
Every two seconds.
So we're just waiting for it to come
back up.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Were we we were editing
that in place, weren't we?
Yes. We were.
So remember that bug, KubeCuddle?
Yeah. It came up, though. Kubelet. First the
first time. Okay. Alright.
We we were being positive here. It came
up Oh, there it is. Kubelet has that
bug where it sometimes won't read a file
you edit in place. So That's true. Do
I look better a little? Alright.
Let's see if the API server came to
life.
Nope. Not yet. So
let's check the API server log.
Yep.
Alright. Oops. Let's just do this tail.
Reverse flow.
View
server.
Context deadline succeeded. Come on. That's what you
get. You were right. 127.
Go for it, Christian. Yeah. The the look
close was the
Alright.
So,
what was the IP again, Ron? Do you
still have that new buffer?
Oh, go ahead. Sorry. No. I I just
killed you. No. I didn't.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. The
it's a servers flag. Right? So Yep. I
think that's normal, guys.
Yeah. This one? Localhost is normal.
What's normal? For API server. That setting.
Oh, connecting to the to
the NCD via localhost is normal. So Right.
Resolving a problem that's not a problem.
Oh, come on.
So what I'm gonna do is I'll grab
that because there is something that caught my
eye inside the the
YAML, and it's it's this one here.
So client URLs are client connections.
It's listening for on this IP address
and Alright. Not
local host.
So
let's w q out of that.
And, Ron, let's do your
The local one should work too. I mean,
it's the same.
Right. Everybody's if everybody's if it's listening to
zero zero zero.
That's true.
I mean
So now we have to wait for etcd
to come back up. Hey. Oh, there it
is. I guess I guess you're right. Alright.
Guess I'm on. I'll shut up now. What's
Kubernetes? I've never heard of it. I know.
Right?
So let's Alright. Wait. Yeah. That should been
fine.
Oh, come on. Get pods. Don't be cruel.
This is like killing hello world. Why did
we kill hello world?
What did Hello World do to you? I
haven't checked the API server logs. I I'm
not convinced you have the API server and
STD talking to each other yet.
Yeah. That's right.
Well, that log is
that's the wrong log file because that's four
or five minutes old now.
It's the but it's
oh, it did sorry. You're right. You're right.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Delete faster. Delete. Delete.
Oh, yeah. Now I don't know which one
is the latest.
Number one, right, or something like that because
it rotates.
Right.
What am I looking on here?
For 1727,
just about a couple minutes ago. So 90D.
Yeah. Just a 3. Yeah. Yeah. They had
a comma one before, but I don't see
that now.
Whatever.
Oh, man. Some somebody heard our ETCD.
Storage key not found.
Registering master leases.
Alright.
Type this wrong. Kube admin reset.
I will read that read those two error
messages slowly.
The one above the story chatter. I think
you're missing something.
So we
got this.
Oh, so oh.
Alright.
Our
this is this is coming from our admin.
No way. Explain it, Ron. Explain what you
saw. So for the audience It's cube system
is misspelled.
Yeah.
System or system with no e.
Where am I looking? Am I so you're
looking here.
Nope. Don't think it's in there.
Is this not where you set it?
It's in here. Right? Like Or
Hold on. Let me set that up.
I'm looking for the namespace.
Works.
Isn't it in our
cube config file? Am I blind?
No. Not unless you said it explicitly.
So that would mean it would be going
to default.
Was I supposed to API server log? Yeah.
It's you're looking at our admin comp here.
So
Oh, wait a second. Yeah. This is for
the. Manifest
hold on.
These manifest a p error,
q API
error.
There
we go. There it is.
Womp.
Someone drop me a womp, please.
Alright. How do you have the
somebody has a this is lot of typos.
Somebody should really
was this was this Ron or me typing?
Is that what happened? Did we make this
kind of a This wasn't a hack job.
This this was just
my bad skill. We got
how many API servers we got going here?
We got two of them now.
That's not good.
Hey. We're in stereo now. Hey. It worked.
One
of the API servers worked.
It's horizontally scaled.
That's right. Oh, there's Amazon Just update the
and that's it. Just update the pod.
Alright. Alright. Someone else take over. I'm too
nervous.
Alright. I'll go ahead. First off, let's get
all our pods
and all of our namespaces. Wait. Wait. Yeah.
Wait a second. Where's the app? It should
be showing up in the get it should
be in the default namespace.
Where's our default namespace?
We are in the default namespace.
Oh, wait. Why don't we where's our app
and where's Postgres?
Let's
see.
Trickery.
I called make it explicit. Do dash end
default and check.
Alright. Maybe the maybe there's some crafty thing
where they've e b f'd us.
I don't think you'd be e b p
f. I mean, if you look at your
cube system namespace, you've got one important thing
at an address space. Right? Yeah.
That's true. So let's
yeah. So that means that the deployments
And the controller manager is kind of important.
Right? Yeah. Oh, yeah. But, well, we don't
need the controller manager if we bypass it.
Yeah.
That and a cluster has also been scaled
down all the way too.
Same with the STS, I believe.
The stable set, I mean, for Alright. Well,
the controller manager needs to get fixed. That's
why these are zero. So let's let's go
after that.
Alright.
Ron, I'll leave you to the go ahead.
I heard it I heard it works if
you
let it restart 200 times. Maybe we should
just wait.
The two hundredth time.
It's like, yes. Oh, come on. Overcome my
difficulties.
Oh, really? Come on. Here. I can't I
can't live like this, like a caveman anymore.
Alright. Here. I got I've got your Hold
on. I've got that on the buffer. Completion
bash. Alright. I'm I'm no I'm no longer
a caveman.
Alright. Describe.
Pod. Describe pod.
Why can't I just read my mind? Come
on. Of course, my mind's empty. So you
know?
Alright.
Image is here.
Boom. Boom. Crash.
Why are we crashing?
Yeah. Let's check our logs on it.
Yeah. Why can't you be friendly?
You can use Kube CTL logs now, Ron.
Savage.
Alright.
Alright. We got two logs here. Who's who's
the newer log? The top guy is the
newer log.
Right? 17331738.
Alright. Now let's go open this guy.
Adam.
Alright. I'll start walking backwards.
Missing
time stamp.
Sorry. Tell me to go slow if we're
going slower. I'm just kinda
seeing if there's, like, a big cat. I'm
looking for ASCII art. Where's the big thing
saying you got hacked?
I don't I don't see it.
How far back in time? We're still at
seventeen thirty three. Oh, this is at the
top. Port has been deprecated.
This flag has
no effect.
Well,
maybe some kind of studying here.
What is happening here?
Starting.
Waiting.
Let's see. Did the
should maybe check to see if it crashed
because it is oh, wait a minute. Can
we do, like, dash p?
Oh, yeah. Keep pill logs. Yep.
Like
yeah. Let me
use
the use the tools.
There we go.
So
That's a big stack. Dash p is the
previous container, the one that's
previous crash is what we're looking at. Right.
Look at all this Go code.
Expository.
You wanna type it to a picture so
we can we can follow along?
Oh, it's
a oops. Sorry. My bad. I thought I
I thought I had it in BI. That
was my my bad.
Okay.
Here we go. Let's check failed.
Failed to wait for API server being
oh, wait. For API server was down at
that point, but that it was down back
then, I think. That's why you've had to
look at the previous logs. Because it's restarted
since we were talking about it. Yeah. Maybe
now it's healthy.
Yeah. Maybe.
Do like it when things fix themselves?
Right?
There we go. Hey. Hey. Round of the
clock. We're restart all the through.
Yeah. Just have to restart until it started
again. You know? Wait. Wait. Automation automation works.
Wait. We still don't have a default
anything.
I know. Right. Where's our Just scale up
just scale up the deployment.
Alright. Christian, go. It was at zero?
Yep.
Get deployed. Christian. So alright. So then I'll
do keep pedals. Good.
Show it no mercy. Deploy one.
Deploy clustered.
Was it one? Yeah. Yeah. Let's just do
one for now.
Oh my gosh.
K. Forgot a
getting close. Gonna check if we have our
pod first.
Right. It is currently pending.
You
oh, you cursing schedule, are you?
Yeah. Let's just grab this pot here.
It's been No. No. It's tank.
Wait a minute. Why is it going?
Yeah. What's going to the next one? We
don't need to we don't need a machine.
It's true. Just get it. Just remove the
tank.
The clock's ticking.
Yeah.
So I'm going to so they're currently scheduled,
so that means they're not accepting new loads
from the scheduler.
So we'll do cube cuddle uncoordin raft
was it uncoordin node? Raft worker one?
I don't think you need to it. It's
just uncoordinate raft worker one, I think. Yeah.
There you go. And two.
Alright.
Oh, we just need one in. Yeah. Just
come on. It may be it may have
an affinity for the
master.
Right? Alright. Because it's zero of one nodes.
So I'm guessing the the deployment has a,
affinity.
Yeah. So that's what I'm gonna check for
by clicking at the YAML.
Yeah. And oh, right. Let's go.
There you go. There you go.
So
Wait. Cluster d d d d d. That's
a lot of t's right there.
So we're gonna have to fix that. That's
the way it goes. The show. It's cluster.
Alright. You gotta fill that buffer for, you
what we tell people.
I don't see any affinities. Do you, Chris
or Ron?
You gotta search, man. Do do you're in
VI or less.
I'm on less. Hit
forward slash.
Forward slash. Okay. Forward slash. And then backslash
c, lowercase c,
and then
you said taint. You just look for taint.
Right? Yeah.
You don't need to do capital t. The
the backslash c was case insensitive.
Alright. Hold
I was Oh, yeah. No.
You're looking for a taint is a node
taint. You're looking for
node selector or an affinity, so look for
it would be under the pod spec. So
go well, so
We're on dot containers. I don't see node.
I don't see n.
I don't see affinity.
Alright. We'll fix the fix the image. Alright.
So
Watch. That is the name.
There you go. That's the So we'll
do we'll edit it and Minimum
replicas unavailable.
Because we And then I say forget it.
Just untaint the masternode and
Yeah. That's true. You know? Who cares? Isn't
that what we did?
No. We yeah. I did the the workers.
Oh, man. Come on, man. I said
Oh, no. That's still
it's still
Replicating out of control? Oh, yeah. Just just
to do your just remove the master tint.
Right. Keep cuddle. What was a taint? I'm
sorry, guys.
Keep cuddle, taint.
No.
And then you can do all. Yeah.
Kubernetes.
IOS slash. Yeah. So so so so It's
node dash role dot Kubernetes dot I o
slash master.
Okay.
So
node Why can't autocomplete fix this?
Right.
So it was
node It's 2021.
Come on.
Alright. There you go.
Yep.
There
we go.
No. Okay. Error image pull. Okay. So it's
still
the
thing is still not going through.
Plus third?
Third. Yeah. Edie. It's d. It's it's it's
not no. Wait. It's not e d. It's
d. Clustered.
They're creating.
It's it's creating. We're good.
Oh, wait. Did it oh, I I can't
spell then.
It is easy. I can't either.
Right? I was trying to Alright.
We got, like, four minutes left, so
it'll get pods. It's running.
Alright.
Wait. I forgot to start the timer on
time, so you've actually got a bit longer.
So you're you're good. Okay. Okay. Alright. Wait.
Go. Go. Go. We gotta do a set
set image now to version two.
Alright. Right. So keep Cuddle
set. We we might we might drop on
step one or two. Deploy
clustered.
And then what was it? It was what
was the what was the name? I don't
know the name of the container, dude. Mean,
it was Scroll up. Scroll up, aren't didn't
you just show that? Or Containers is
clustered. It's just called clustered.
That's the Oh, yeah. If it's just the
deployment, I think it's the same name. Right?
Yeah. Whatever. We'll we'll find out.
Oh, wait. Don't get cocky yet. We're so
close. Yeah.
Dude, good time.
What do you Rollout history. Rollout history. See
if it's oh, you didn't record the rollout
history, dude. Come on now. They they deprecated
it.
Oh, wow. That's been awful. There's been a
lot of changes made to this one. But,
yeah, no. I didn't, I did not record
the rollout history. So let's see what's our
next move for this one. Just describe the
pod and see if it says v two,
and then let's open up the browser and
see if it worked.
Oh, you've you've got a few more things
to fix before it work. You just you've
you've just not seen them yet.
That was the angel of death talking.
So it is not ready, though, unfortunately.
So, unfortunately, it looks like we gotta we
do have a couple more things.
It seems to be failing.
It's a
readiness probe, if there is one. Delete the
readiness probe.
Go for it. I like you. Thank you.
Yeah. Alright. Go fast.
Rariness probe. Yeah. No.
Don't don't do this. Kids don't do this.
Forget that. Just forget that there was a
Rariness probe. You know? It's, it's fine.
It's also a
also a rogue replica set that seems to
be trying to do something. Not sure what's
up with that fella.
But it's ready now.
Woo hoo. Alright.
Wait. Wait. We're not done. There could be,
like, a service blocker, you know, or something
like that. We we we gotta make sure
we can Okay. So this is where I
would encourage that I will go to the
teleport page. I click on applications and we
have a nice little helper to launch our
clustered app.
And what you want to see is me
dancing.
Are we gonna see me No.
I wanna see you dancing. Come on up.
Oh, no. Build to connect to database. Because
our
Postgres is not up.
Yep. It's actually gone.
Get
deployed. What if a stable timed out. Alright.
Is it scaled scaling?
Or
Well, there is no stable set. So Yeah.
Was Postgres
Yes.
On its own? Or
Yeah. So there's there's a cluster IP, but
there's no
Yeah. There's no there's no database,
unfortunately. That's such a shame.
So
oh, no. That's such a shame.
But we got the pod up and running.
So what's next? Yeah. Who who needs data?
Right?
Also, what's up with Ambassador
being down. That's a bug I need to
fix. Don't worry about that. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
That's
yeah. That's that's fine.
So We slow slow down. So there's no
Postgres pod. Do we have Postgres YAML? Is
that in this command? The YAML from github.com/rawcode/clustered.
Oh, okay.
So There's a workload directory.
Slash raw code slash
cluster.
Clustered.
Oh, cluster. Right.
Clustered. Train node e.
And inside the workload directory, you'll find opt
Kubernetes,
and you'll see
Opt Kubernetes. Everything there? Yeah. Postgres is there.
There you go. Oops. Not blame. I don't
wanna blame. That seems dirty deleting the actual
code.
Yeah. Right? We should we should have just
deleted the Kubernetes repo.
You got the answer. That's
not gonna work.
What happened? Set pace there.
Yeah. Hey.
I
was gonna say, you could just it's a
public repo. You could just keep CTL apply
it from. Hey. He wanted to do the
caveman art where you blow paint on your
hand. Right? Fine. Yeah. Yeah. That's true.
Alright. So let's do keep pedal apply my
apply minus f from
that guy.
Oh, look at you being all fancy pants.
I'll do that. That's right there.
Unchanged.
Unchanged created.
Get some pods.
PV and our PVCs. Just make sure that
it's not, you know, backed by anything. Alright?
So Or
it should be backed by something.
Yeah. Or if it should be backed by
something. Let's go check that repo there. Boot
you up, man.
Probably has a probe or something, so taking
a second here. Likely. Yep. Do it. So
oh, go ahead. Sorry. Yeah. Sorry.
Alright. So Alright. Alright. Let me refresh our
clustered application.
Oh,
yeah. Hey.
You got the pants. You well done. Nice.
You go. Nice.
Alright. Good job. There there was a lot
to fix there. Right?
Yeah.
Did did we beat the time? You did.
I mean, I I started the timer late,
so I'm not actually sure how long it
was. But it was I think you were
under the the forty minutes. I think you
were okay.
There was twelve minutes left on the timer
and I started ten minutes late. So I
think you had three minutes left.
Alright.
You just got a minute. What you mean
there was one second left and we defused
the bomb? Exactly. Yeah. Awesome. Yeah. That that's
how it went.
We'll edit the video to reflect that. Don't
you worry. But then, no, good job. That
was good teamwork. You communicated well. You worked
through lots and lots of typos and death
by a dozen cuts there almost. But you
got to the end. Oh, yeah. Deleting the
stateful set, I thought was particularly sneaky.
But there you go.
Alright. Awesome. That was a lot of fun.
That was fun. Yeah. Yeah. That really was.
So so we should go to the YouTube
now and watch watch
hopefully, the reverse penalty.
It's it's a different video because of the
small hiccup that we experienced at the start.
But if you go to Rawkode.live,
you'll be able to see that we have
a session live in action. So feel free
to jump out of this call, jump over
there, and we'll have
the Rav team join us in just a
moment. So thanks again. Well done. I'll speak
to you all soon.
Alright. Alright. Thanks. Good luck. Go Rav. Thank
you.
Alright. So the Rav team will be coming
to join us in just a moment once
I I'll just boot out all the There
we go.
So Rawkode team, come and say hello. While
we wait, just because of the awkward start,
I'm going to thank the sponsors again.
Teleport, we've been using since the start of
Clustered is an amazing product. Check it out
at rockwood.liveteleport.
I really appreciate that. And Equinix Medal, my
former employer, has been very gracious and continues
to sponsor the hardware that we use on
Clustered as well. So if you want to
check out a bare metal cloud, you can
use the code Rawkode for 200 USD in
credits. Go spin up some bare metal.
Alright. We have the Rawkode team. So let's
bring them in. Hello. Hello. Hello.
How's it going? How was that? Was that
fun to watch?
It was a blast. Are you Sure was.
Screaming at the television going, Josh, it's right
there.
No. That was a great job. Was hard.
Alright. Well, thank you again. Can we start
with a little bit of introductions?
We'll just start with you on the left
there, Hitesh, and then we'll move over, and
then we'll get started with the the next
cluster.
Sure. So hey, everybody. I'm Hitesh Sharma. So
I'm a senior engineer at Raft,
and I was I've been playing with Kubernetes
for about a couple years now. So really
excited to see what we have to fix
here now.
And I'm.
I'm the lead RNG engineer at Raft. I've
been working with Kubernetes for a little bit
over three years now.
Really excited to see what they broke up
in this cluster.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you very much. So let's
get my screen shared.
There we go.
I'm going to open a session on the
control plane node of this cluster.
If you could please go to activity and
active sessions and join this session, just give
me an echo hello to let me know
that you're there and then we'll kick
things off.
There we go. One.
Alright. Let me refresh.
Remember, it's under activity and active session.
Got it.
Alright. I can see we also have the
RXM team in the chat saying, let's go.
So they're prepared for this too. There we
go.
And we got you both here. Sweet. So
export your KubeConfig, test for an API server.
Best of luck. Take it away.
Alright, bro. Go for it.
I'll I'll I'll wait ten minutes when I
start the timer. That's
what I did with the first cluster.
See what we got.
That's alright. I jumped on. We can go
home. I think we're done.
Alright.
K. Everything is running.
I hope they I hope they remember to
break it.
What do you wanna do? Edit the deployment?
Let's
see. I was gonna check if we can
get to the application.
Yep. Do you want me to fill it
up?
So Sure. We go to applications.
We'll spin up clustered.
Yep. Version one does appear to be working.
As well. Okay.
Let's try v two.
Just added the deployment. Let's see.
Adding some of the shortcuts.
Let's see what we have there.
It too?
Yep. Let's try.
Interesting. A lot of
alright. So
let's see.
Check the scheduler.
Go for it. You have access.
K. That looks good.
Just do the
unexpected
end of file.
Yeah.
Did they put some tabs in the YAML?
Like, there's a connection refused too.
Yeah. End
of file. I mean, these error messages do
appear to be from
yesterday.
Let's see what they did.
Oh, wow. Look at that.
I think that's just me. Okay.
Yeah. There's nothing there.
We tried. That's not how we tried. Nice
try though.
So
So let's talk about what happened there. Right?
You did a cube control edit of the
deployment and you believe you've set the version
to be v two. Can you and nothing's
happened. So maybe you wanna confirm that?
Yeah. They're described on the on the deployment.
Did they mess around with our back?
K. Alright. So that's v two.
But zero replicas created for the new replica
set.
What's responsible for on the replica sets?
So this one is not ready.
This is the new one.
Where is my mouse?
Non existent.
Yeah.
Isn't that clicking on the window?
What do you what are you trying to
do?
Describe the the new
RS.
Let's let's do the
do we do the source completion?
Yep. User forbidden.
Service account.
Now let's look let's look and take take
a look at the
I wonder
if
What are you wondering?
Talk to me. I'm trying
to think if
the if the service account should have had
labels
to access that.
So the
user we're seeing under the
gray
isn't the default service account.
Because you described the default service account and
the default namespace,
but this is the replica
controller
and part of the controller manager.
Yeah. This is this is from the cube
system.
Can you do describe service accounts in the
cube system?
Now let's look at the
Just get all of them.
K.
Let's do describe.
Same
one. But what I'm trying to look for
Isn't it gonna be for the replica set,
though?
Is there an error around the replica set?
The replica set controller?
Yeah.
K.
So service account doesn't have any permissions, right,
in the Kubernetes cluster?
What do we have to look at next?
If the service account has no permission.
Well, We'll
need to look at binding?
Yeah. Exactly. Let's look at the role bindings
and see if we can mark out what's
going wrong here. Go for it, Brock.
Oh,
we forgot you saw our favorite tool.
Yeah. Hey. You know what? I'm stopping let's
stop being a caveman.
He thinks there's good one. Yeah.
Yeah.
Alright.
I gotta do the export thing.
Yep.
K.
Let's get the role
binding. Is that a roll binding missing then?
Is this all for the
no.
Sorry. Sounds
about right.
Is there any role?
Say that again?
Who?
Roles.
Yeah.
Okay. Let's go back to the error because
I feel like we've
Yep. Maybe gone too deep into one place.
Got a deployment and see your replica sets.
Yeah.
Bout to create
user system service account cube system, replica set
controller.
So we just need to give access to
replica set controller.
Yeah. We need to,
give it a a role binding.
Yeah.
So for that,
we can do
That's tying this one. Right?
Yeah.
Okay. Do you have that, up?
Checking real quick.
That is evil. Well, I guess service account
is fair.
It's making me question some of my
knowledge here because I I can't remember if
the controller manager rule back are
hard coded
or not.
I'd I actually expected to see more
from a kubectl get rule bindings. Ah, but
it may be a cluster rule binding. We
don't look at those.
So I would do a get cluster
cluster role binding
on the cube or the span of the
namespace.
There you go. That's looking much better. Now
we can see that we have the replica
set controller role binding there bind into the
cluster role of replica set controller. So you're
gonna wanna start
introspecting
those two.
The arrow binding doesn't
so we need to give axe
when the default namespace, I'm assuming that's correct?
This
rule binding here,
I'm gonna I'm gonna assume binds our replica
set controller
service account to this cluster rule. So maybe
start by just taking a look at that
cluster role and see what permissions it has.
You wanna do a describe on that?
I'm just gonna check something.
For it. Go for it. While while I'm
looking something, you can go for
The
replica set controller.
Yeah. So cluster role space. And then alright.
Yeah. That way works too.
Seems okay.
Create,
list, delete, update.
I think we're missing a verb
in pods.
Yeah.
Create, aren't we?
Do edit.
Is it over here? Am I in the
right place? Yeah. You'll need to search for
pods.
There we go.
It still doesn't seem like it's coming up.
Might have to
kill it.
Again.
Alright.
Might have to trigger it again
Or not.
Sorry.
Deployment.
Image.
I'm downgrading it back to v one. Okay.
And then putting it on v two.
I can't create because it did something or
thought it did something, but it doesn't look
like it is picking up the changes
yet.
So let's take a look at the the
the logs of the deployment again. And you
could just delete that replica there, and it
it should force it to recreate it.
There you go.
I mean, it's still not creating a pod,
but
Let's see what this Oh, different error. There
you go. Cited quota.
Oh, that's fine. We can just delete that
other part, and it should be fine. Yeah.
I mean, sneaky, but it's no.
Pending.
That's v two? Well, it's still v one,
though.
Because that is still gonna deploy v one.
Yeah. The
the deployment is set to v two right
now. Right?
The deployment
is
set to v two.
V two.
So replica failure failed to create. What is
what is this saying?
Minimum replicas unavailable.
But I think this needs to be edited.
Yeah.
See
if there are any
gotchas here.
And that threshold,
period, success.
That status, that's not gonna make a difference.
So path is good, which
we know,
because that was one of the things we
had broke.
We need to edit the
we shouldn't need to edit the image
from the replica side. Right? That should be
picked up from the deployment?
Correct.
So if you see a a an error
message about quotas,
what parameters does Kubernetes expose for quotas? Do
you know?
I don't remember from the top of my
head. That's gonna be
there was a second one. Or is it
the
Unless they tainted all the no no. But
then it would complain about a taint if
they did it with taint.
There's a sub command, kubectl API dash resources,
which will list all the custom resources or
all the resource definitions within a cluster.
Not not necessarily a customer. I had to
correct myself there. I don't know if you
can do this in canines. We may have
to use vanilla cube control. Uh-uh. Uh-uh.
Yeah. You found a quarter. There you go.
But
it's set to two, so
it should be okay still. But I guess
we could increase these to three.
Or you could delete the quota. I I
prefer the shotgun approach.
Delete it. I'm
not gonna say how, but that might have
been how some stuff disappeared from that previous
cluster or that the previous team there.
Was trying to to debug.
But do we need to trigger this again?
No. It thinks it's on v two. Might
have to delete the replica set, though, again.
Oh, just speed up the reconciliation.
Oh,
something is pending.
Yep. Let's see. That seems to be a
v two.
Yep. I'm I'm half expecting an ingress mess
or something. And why is it pending forever?
If you look at the log
So
Do they have any tolerations on the thing?
I don't know. Can you look at the
GitHub and see that they they mess up
this deployment?
Yep.
There's no logs to it.
There's
nothing in here in the deployment necessarily.
The replica set
says that it successfully
created.
Still in pending mode. Okay.
Normally,
for something that's stuck in pending mode, we'd
see
an event for where it was scheduled and
an event for the image being pulled. We're
not really seeing that.
No. It's not pulling images.
Wonder why we're not pulling And it's not
gonna say the node check if you look
at that. Do it describe on the nodes?
I just wanna see, like, if there's anything
blocking.
K.
Up and running. Unscheduled.
Unscheduled.
Yeah.
Oh.
Very Kubelet has sufficient memory available. Disk pressure.
It filled up the disk, didn't they?
No. This is no no disk pressure. I
think you're okay.
Oh, okay. Oh, no. No. Status is false.
Hold on. Hold on. I'm reading this wrong.
That note appears to be healthy.
That's sufficient memory available.
So to what was it going to mean?
I think this is and I think
it's too late to come up. Yeah.
It doesn't seem like there's anything here that's
being overused.
If you go back to your podcast, let
me find names first.
Right. So
the the one thing that right now is
is pending with no nodes. So you can
either bypass the scheduler or maybe look at
why the scheduler is not assigned to that
node. You got two different options. That was
my my next thing is to look at
the scheduler and see if something
is messed up there because it's putting this
on the control plane.
Right?
Can you pop can you put
this under the control plane too and see?
So this is one of my favorite hacks
with Kubernetes, but the scheduler is really, really
simple. I mean, you can just modify the
deployment and put the node into the spec
and then bypass the scheduler altogether.
A cool hack.
But nobody should ever do it in production
ever.
I don't think anybody should do any
of the Kubernetes in production. That there's the
answer to everything.
I'm checking the
scheduler.
Right after that spec line, you can literally
just put node name and then the name
of a node.
Oh, really? Okay. Yeah. I did not know
that. Did I know?
Go grab that name of a node.
Oh, okay. It should be fairly easy to
remember.
Wait.
Connection refused.
I don't like that.
Was it camel cased? It is. Yeah.
If I've remembered it correctly.
We'll find out.
Oh, I did not wanna say it. Name
is not correct. You'll need look at another
pod. You'll be able to see it there
because the scheduler adds it.
Like at the pod, you mean? Or or
Yeah. Oh, not pod. Look at the YAML.
Yeah. Because it it gets added to the
pod, you can set it. Oh, no. You
have to set it on the pod spec
within the deployment YAML. I'm just being silly.
We have to go through the deployment, go
down to spec, template spec, and then set
note in.
Oh, I see. What can we move around
the Yeah. Wrong spec.
It won't be the container.
It'll be the
Oh, it would be at the At the
same level as containers. Yeah.
Was such a good idea.
There we go.
Well, something got scheduled.
We did.
So it's b two.
Do we wanna see if the URL is
exploding or not?
I I really hope that horrible hack is
not just ended this episode. Got
it. It has side effects. I blame you.
Me too is up.
It could just be my browser cache.
So I've had to hit refresh 40,000 times
before
I
think Is that it? Oh, damn it. We
fixed it.
It did stop my end. Yep. There we
go.
Alright. I didn't know that was gonna be
the end of the the carnage. No. I
feel bad. Yeah.
Oh, well, it's fixed. I wonder I wonder
if we're missing stuff, but those are those
are some pretty low
downfalls.
I mean, we still haven't fixed technically the
the node. Right? We kinda hacked our way.
Just, yeah, something running.
So do you want do you want to
attempt to fix the scheduler? Or do you
wanna just call it you've you've that's it.
You've done it. It's it's good.
I don't know. I'm okay with saying it's
good. Good enough. Enough. Right? It's deployed to
production. The site's live. Let's not touch it.
Yeah. Alright.
Perfect. Well, good job.
We we flew through that one. Some
fun things to fix there. The scheduler is
always a fun one.
I mean, the scheduler does a lot, but
it's really easy just to bypass it and
move on to something else. So Yeah.
Alright. Well, that was fun. Two two good
clusters. Did what did you prefer? Watching someone
fix yours or fixing someone else's?
I preferred
the fixing part because
I think like, you're sitting at the screen,
like, just throwing popcorn at it. I'm like,
come on. I
mean, when we were watching, was the whole
time, I just wanted to tap in the
chat. Like, no. No. Look at that namespace.
Look at the namespace. There's a typo there.
So
but, I mean, they did a great job
too. I mean, we we also had some
lot of
small cuts on the worker nodes as well,
but then the workaround for them was also
just to spin up the application on the
control plane. So that worked out as well
because there was no way the worker nodes
were coming up.
Ah, right. Okay. Yeah. I don't I don't
think I noticed that. Yeah. Yeah. We had
a lot of small little cuts. We'll we'll
put it in the PR,
But that was that was sort of RMO.
It's just a fat finger, a bunch of
stuff that nobody ever should touch
in themselves. Right? Like, the search Getting up
gates.
Yeah. Especially
the search on the worker nodes. Yeah.
Alright. Sweet. Well, thank you for taking time
out of your day and week. You know,
breaking those clusters is not easy. It takes
time. And thank you for joining me live
and, you know, typing in front of people,
which is also impending doom every time we
do it. So as thanks for sharing your
knowledge and a good job. I'll let you
both get back to your day and I'll
say goodbye to everyone else. Thanks.
Alright.
Two great teams, two great clusters. That was
a whole lot of fun. Apologies for the
weirdness with the YouTube video at the start.
I do not know what happened there. I'm
gonna have to dig into that. Thank you
to our sponsors again, Teleport and Equinix Medal.
We use Teleport to debug these customers, to
fix them, to share terminals, to get access.
It's a really neat open source product that
everybody,
literally everybody should check out and have running
in their production infrastructure.
If want to know more, go to Rawkode.liveteleport.
I would really appreciate that. And EquinixMetal provided
the hardware. If you want to check out
Bare Metal Cloud for yourself, it is a
whole lot of fun. Use the code Rawkode
for $200 in credit.
Alright. We will be back soon with more
clustered and even more at the Rawkode Academy.
Things will be getting back to normal now,
almost. I have finished my paternity leave. Lots
more coming soon. Thank you for enjoying and
watching with us. I'll see you all soon.
Thank you.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.